so late last week Joe Russa went live on
duello bars Instagram and did a live QA
duello is a bar that Joe Russo owns a
part of and during this live Q&A he
answered many questions about Avengers
four and one of the questions that he
answered was about the current running
time of Avengers 4 he also answered
questions about how far along in the
editing process they are currently with
Avengers 4
all right Danny fan DX M wants to know
how far long is Avengers 4 in the
editing process we are we're about
halfway through the editing process
we're really just scratching the surface
on all of our VFX shots there are more
than 3000 we effects shots the movie
does require a lot of time and thought
and energy and effort I think we're very
early in that phase of getting the
effects done we just started working
down semester in score
so as you can see here he said that the
current running time for Avengers 4 is
sitting at 3 hours a lot of people think
that because he said this Avengers 4 is
going to be 3 hours long at least this
is not the case he said that they are
currently sitting at 3 hours he didn't
say that the movie is 3 hours long and
he also said we'll see if that holds he
goes on to talk about the editing
process and about how they really
haven't even began to scratch the
surface yet the editing process
basically goes on until the movie comes
out in theaters in fact they had to push
the release date of Infinity Ward back
because of the editing process so
there's going to be a lot of changes
happening which will ultimately affect
the running time for Avengers 4 so what
Joe Russo is really saying is that right
now with all of the editing that we've
done the movie is currently sitting at 3
hours but as we continue to do more
editing it could very well change and it
most likely will not be longer than 3
hours long you have to keep in mind that
the studios have a say in how long the
movies going to be both Marvel Studios
and Disney Studios they have however
told us that it's going to be longer
than Avengers infinity war which sat at
2 hours and 40 minutes but also keep in
mind that some of that is the end
credits so what we're really looking at
here for a runtime for Avengers 4 is
going to be somewhere between 2 hours
and 45 minutes and three hours which is
probably about the perfect runtime for
Avengers for about 3 hours long making
it the longest MCU movie beating Captain
America Civil War and Avengers infinity
war which is very suiting because this
is going to wrap up the first 10 years
of the MCU and kick us off to face 4 so
I wanted to just clear the air a little
bit I've been getting a lot of messages
about people saying that they heard
Avengers 4 is going to be four hours
long 3 and a half hours long at least
three hours long probably longer none of
that is officially confirmed again a lot
of editing going on but it looks like
we're probably sitting right at three
hours for Avengers 4 so let me know your
thoughts let me know what you think the
perfect run time would be for Avengers 4
and I'm still giving away copies of
Infinity Ward Deadpool 2 and ant-man and
the wasp as well as some special edition
posters all you have to do for your
chance to win is subscribe to my channel
like the video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]
you